En 2019 China y Rusia llevaron su relación
un paso más allá.
Ambos países elevaron su cooperación al
grado, abro comillas, de “asociación estratégica
integral de coordinación global”.
Que, ¿Cómo os quedáis?
Sea como sea, lo cierto es que hablamos del
mejor momento en la relación entre estas
dos potencias.
Dos países que en tiempos de Mao llegaron
a protagonizar un montón de rifirrafes fronterizos.
El caso es que este buen entendimiento debería
suponer un impulso a la Organización de Cooperación
de Shanghái, ¿habéis escuchado hablar de
ella?
Se trata de una institución formal liderada
por Pekín y Moscú que tiene como punto de
atención Asia Central.
Sin embargo, amigos, el futuro de esta organización
regional ofrece más interrogantes que certezas,
entre otras cosas porque parece que los intereses
de China y Rusia no discurren por los mismos
caminos.
Así que en VisualPolitik nos hemos hecho
unas cuantas preguntas:
¿En qué consiste exactamente esta Organización
de Cooperación de Shanghái?
¿Realmente se llevan tan bien Rusia y China?
Y la cuestión que resulta aún más importante,
¿Qué futuro tiene la relación entre estos
dos gigantes?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas.
Pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de Historia.
(Pero Stop.
Un momento y mucha atención.
Antes de seguir queremos presentaros un nuevo
proyecto con el que estamos colaborando: “Si
lo Hubiera Sabido”, un nuevo canal de información
financiera con el que podréis estar al día
de todo lo que ocurre en los mercados.
Pilotado por Mutuactivos, este canal aspira
a convertirse en toda una ventana al mundo
del dinero, las bolsas y la renta variable.
Por ejemplo, ¿Sabías que la inversión en
bolsa protegió a los inversores durante las
grandes crisis, incluso en la mismísima Argentina
del corralito?
¿Cómo se están recuperando exactamente
las principales economías tras el impacto
del coronavirus?
¿Cuál ha sido la mayor OPV del año en China?
¿Cómo funcionan exactamente los mercados?
Estas son queridos amigos, amigas algunas
de las preguntas a las que este nuevo canal
de Mutuactivos pretende responder.
Ëchale un vistazo y no olvides suscribirte.
Merece la pena, lo vais a comprobar por vosotros
mismos.
Os dejamos por aquí y, también, en la descripción
un enlace a su primer vídeo.
Y dicho esto, arranquemos.
(UNIDOS CONTRA LAS TRES FUERZAS DEL MAL)
Moscú está mucho más cerca de Madrid que
de Pekín.
Así que, aunque China y Rusia comparten fronteras,
a sus gobernantes siempre les ha separado
algo más de 6.000km de distancia.
Pese a ello se han cruzado un montón de veces
por el camino.
(La primera mitad del siglo XX fue una época
revolucionaria para Rusia y para China.
El imperio ruso se transformó en la Unión
de Repúblicas Socialistas Soviéticas.
Y el imperio chino culminó su colapso dando
paso a una república dividida y amenazada
continuamente por Japón.
Derrotados los nipones en la Segunda Guerra
Mundial, el Partido Comunista de China se
alzó victorioso en la guerra civil.
Rusia y China pasaban a estar unidas… al
menos desde un punto de vista ideológico.)
La Guerra Fría dividió el mundo en dos grandes
bloques.
La URSS y China se unieron como las grandes
potencias comunistas aliadas contra el Occidente
capitalista.
Sin embargo amigos, todo se torció tras la
muerte de Stalin.
Digamos, que quedó vacante el título de
macho alfa del comunismo.
Y así comenzó una enorme rivalidad entre
Moscú y Pekín por ver quién era el más
comunista de todos.
Y Mao apostó fuerte.
Tan lejos llegó la disputa que en 1969 hubo
enfrentamientos entre las tropas soviéticas
y chinas a lo largo de la frontera.
(Pero ahí no quedó todo.
Desde principios de los años 70 China comenzó
a cooperar con Estados Unidos para formar
una pinza con la que frenar a la Unión Soviética.
De esta forma hasta finales de los años ochenta,
la URSS mantuvo 44 divisiones desplegadas
a lo largo de sus más de 6.000 kilómetros
de frontera con China, 13 divisiones más
que las que tenía apostadas en el frente
occidental contra la OTAN.)
En cualquier caso, tras la caída de la URSS,
en los años 90 comenzó un acercamiento entre
Rusia y China que dio lugar a los Shanghai
Five.
Y sí, este podría ser el nombre del grupo
más rompedor del pop chino.
Pero en realidad estos Shanghai Five eran
China, Rusia y 3 antiguas repúblicas soviéticas:
Kazajistán, Kirguistán y Tayikistán.
Los 5 se reunieron por primera vez en Shanghai
en 1996, y precisamente de ahí procede el
nombre de los Shanghai Five.
Estas reuniones tenían un objetivo muy claro:
resolver de una vez por todas las disputas
fronterizas, las ya clásicas entre China
y Rusia y otras más recientes que surgieron
tras la disolución de la URSS.
El caso es que los Cinco de Shanghai siguieron
reuniéndose hasta que en 2001 decidieron
dar un paso más.
Uzbekistán quiso sumarse al grupo y tanto
Moscú como Pekín entendieron que aquellas
reuniones podían transformarse en toda una
organización internacional donde abordar
los asuntos de Asia Central.
Así que los Shanghai Five más Uzbekistán
crearon en 2001 la OCS, la Organización de
Cooperación de Shanghai, con sede en… atentos
amigos, que esta es pregunta de Trivial, porque
su sede no se fijó en Shanghái, sino que
se estableció en Pekín.
Respecto al funcionamiento de la organización,
la Carta de la OCS recogió el compromiso
de que las decisiones oficiales se tomarían
por consenso y que ningún miembro se metería
en los asuntos internos del resto.
También entonces se firmó otro documento
fundamental.
Hablamos de la Convención de Shanghái para
combatir las 3 fuerzas del Mal.
Y claro, viendo el historial de los dirigentes,
algún que otro malpensado podría pensar
que esas 3 fuerzas del Mal son la democracia,
la libertad y la independencia de la justicia.
¡Como sois algunos!
Pero no, amigos, esas 3 fuerzas del mal son
el terrorismo, el separatismo y el extremismo
islamista.
Y, ¿sabéis qué?
Estos 6 estados se tomaron muy pero que muy
en serio la lucha contra estas 3 amenazas.
Y desde luego China era el principal interesado
en que así fuera.
(La región autónoma de Xinjiang, la más
occidental de China, es un auténtico polvorín.
Habitado mayoritariamente por etnias musulmanes,
especialmente los uigures, el Partido Comunista
ha multiplicado la presencia de ciudadanos
de etnia han, la predominante en el resto
del país.
Xinjiang limita con Tayikistán y Kazajstán.
Por eso la estabilidad en Asia Central es
importante para la seguridad interna de China.
Digamos que Pekín pretende que estos países
mantengan a raya al extremismo islamista mientras
dentro de sus fronteras reprime a las etnias
musulmanas sin que ninguno de sus vecinos
se atreva a levantar la voz contra el gigante
chino)
Es la ventaja que tiene que todos los países
de la OCS sean regímenes autoritarios.
Que eso de los Derechos Humanos siempre es
algo secundario.
En cualquier caso, lo cierto es que la OCS
logró importantes avances en su particular
cooperación contra las 3 fuerzas del Mal.
Es más: sus miembros realizan frecuentemente
maniobras militares conjuntas.
Pero amigos, la prueba de fuego para esta
alianza llegó en 2014.
Cuando el Kremlin ordenó la invasión de
Crimea, Occidente castigó con sanciones económicas
a Rusia.
Sin embargo, Pekín nunca le hizo un solo
reproche a Putin.
Más bien todo lo contrario.
(Es el viejo amigo del pueblo chino y el más
familiar para el presidente chino de los mandatarios
extranjeros.
Y también mi mejor amigo.
Xi Jinping)
Pero esperad un momento amigos, porque desde
entonces la OCS ha ampliado sus miras.
En 2017, por ejemplo, se incorporaban a la
organización 2 nuevos miembros: India y Pakistán.
De esta forma la organización se expandía
hacia el Índico y ganaba peso como una nueva
alianza internacional dentro del nuevo orden
mundial.
Cumplía así con el gran objetivo que Moscú
y especialmente Pekín se habían marcado.
¿De qué objetivo estamos hablando?
Pues… Atentos.
(EL NUEVO ORDEN MUNDIAL)
Amigos, la entrada de India y Pakistán ha
hecho que la OCS duplique su dimensión.
Y puede que no hayas escuchado hablar de ella,
pero lo cierto es que esta organización abarca
más de 34 millones de km2, ni más ni menos
que el 60% de la región euroasiática; al
tiempo que aglutina más de 3.000 millones
de personas, que aproximadamente es la mitad
de la población mundial.
Además, cuatro miembros de la organización
(Rusia, China, Pakistán e India) son estados
con armas nucleares.
Es decir, que no hablamos precisamente de
una organización poco importante.
La OCS tendría el potencial de convertirse
en una de las organizaciones internacionales
más importantes del mundo.
Y eso, eso es algo que incluso el Tio Sam
lo sabe.
(Durante los primeros años de la OCS, los
mismísimos Estados Unidos solicitaron entrar
bajo el status de Estado observador.
Esta condición suele ser el paso previo a
formar parte de la organización y permite
participar en sus reuniones sin ser miembro
de la misma.
Sin embargo, su solicitud fue rechazada.
Y no solo eso.
La situación en Afganistán e Irak presagiaba
una presencia indefinida de fuerzas estadounidenses
en Uzbekistán y Kirguistán.
Así que la OCS pidió oficialmente a Estados
Unidos que retirara sus tropas de los estados
que formaban parte de la OCS, algo que sucedió
finalmente en 2014.)
Todo un plantón.
Ahora bien, mantener a Estados Unidos lejos
de Asia Central no ha sido su único objetivo.
De hecho, podemos considerar que la OCS es
un instrumento más de la estrategia de China
para construir organizaciones internacionales
al margen de las instituciones que Estados
Unidos diseñó al acabar la Segunda Guerra
Mundial.
(Este es uno de los grandes temas internacionales.
Las potencias occidentales se han mostrado
reacias a modificar las cuotas de poder dentro
de la Organización Mundial del Comercio,
el FMI o el Banco Mundial de una manera que
refleje la creciente influencia económica
y política de China.
En respuesta, China y Rusia se han aliado
para crear nuevos foros y organizaciones en
las que ambas tengan la voz cantante.
En esta línea situamos la OCS, o también,
por ejemplo, el Banco Asiático de Inversión
en Infraestructura, que invade ámbitos del
Banco Mundial.)
Pensadlo un segundo.
La Guerra Fría enfrentó cara a cara a dos
bloques, dos visiones del mundo.
Tras la caída de la Unión Soviética, los
valores liberales, la democracia, los derechos
humanos… ¡eran los valores dominantes en
la escena global!
Pero hoy día eso ya no es exactamente así.
China está actualmente desafiando ese orden
mundial.
Y el Kremlin se ha sumado para justificar
su autoritarismo.
(Los líderes del mundo libre siguen bajando
sus estándares y los autoritarios siguen
ganando terreno.
De vez en cuando, la gente se despierta y
pregunta por qué Putin asesina en el Reino
Unido o piratea en Estados Unidos.
¿Por qué no iba a hacerlo?
Vosotros no lo detuvisteis antes.
Gary Kasparov, gran maestro ruso del ajedrez
y activista político.)
Pero al mismo tiempo que China y Rusia han
plantado cara a Occidente, ambas potencias
también han tratado de sacar el máximo provecho
del buen momento por el que atraviesan sus
relaciones diplomáticas.
Por ejemplo, Rusia es rica en recursos naturales.
Y los que seguís VisualPolitik desde hace
tiempo sabéis que la energía es un ámbito
en el que China tiene un hambre atroz.
De hecho, una cuarta parte de las exportaciones
de crudo de Rusia se dirigen a China.
Y de cara al futuro, Pekín ambiciona el gas
ruso.
Y precisamente, por eso la estatal china CNPC
posee una quinta parte de un megaproyecto
de gas natural licuado en el Ártico ruso
desarrollado por Novatek.
Y a finales de 2019 empezó a funcionar el
gasoducto Power of Siberia, que estará a
pleno rendimiento en 2025.
Hay incluso negociaciones para un segundo
gasoducto.
De completarse ambos, Rusia suministraría
a China más gas natural que el que actualmente
exporta a Alemania.
China es insaciable.
Y quiere más y más.
(Nuestras relaciones bilaterales no han alcanzado
el máximo y pueden mejorar aún más.
Estamos dispuestos a trabajar junto con Rusia
para aumentar continuamente el efecto de la
cooperación de alto nivel de nuestro país,
para que nuestra cooperación pueda dar a
nuestros dos pueblos un mayor sentido de éxito
y para que podamos promover la agenda ruso-china
en los asuntos internacionales.)
Para que os hagáis una idea, ha comenzado
a llegar tanto dinero a Rusia desde China
que el 14% de sus reservas de moneda extranjera
ya son yuanes, algo completamente impensable
en cualquier otro país.
Pero, un momento, si pensáis que lo único
que le interesa a Putin es la pasta china,
y no hablamos precisamente de los noodles,
estáis muy equivocados.
El régimen comunista al otro lado del río
Amur tiene mucho que ofrecer al Kremlin.
Fijaos.
(China y Rusia invierten millones en esta
startup para reconocer tu rostro.)
(Las 105.000 cámaras de reconocimiento facial
de Moscú llegaron para quedarse mientras
el sistema judicial del país afianza la videovigilancia)
Y esto, amigos, es sólo la punta del iceberg
de cómo Moscú quiere aprovechar la tecnología
china.
¿Otro ejemplo?
Huawei desarrollará el 5G de Rusia.
Claro que a cambio de toda esta fuente de
dinero y tecnología, China quiere ampliar
el alcance de la OCS con una estrategia a
largo plazo para integrar económicamente
a todo el continente asiático.
La OCS sería de este modo una vía fundamental
para conectar la costa este de China con los
mercados de Asia Central, Rusia y Europa.
Sin embargo, amigos, que Pekín consiga su
objetivo no será tan sencillo.
¿Por qué?
Atentos.
(EL ABRAZO DEL PANDA)
China se ha convertido en la gran superpotencia
de Asia Central gracias a su espectacular
despertar económico.
Controla economías vecinas como la kazaja,
la tayika y la uzbeka.
Además, se ha convertido en el principal
socio de Turkmenistán, un país que si no
entra en la OCS es porque sus dictadores creen
que Turkmenistán debe ser neutral por encima
de todo.
Pero mucho ojo con los datos, porque lo verdaderamente
importante es que Rusia tampoco es ajena al
poderío chino.
(En 1990 el PIB de la Unión Soviética era
más del doble de grande que el de China.
Hoy en día la situación ha cambiado radicalmente:
el PIB de China es 6 veces mayor que el de
Rusia.
Y mientras Rusia apenas ocupa el décimo lugar
entre los mercados de exportación de China,
ligeramente por encima de Filipinas, China
es el segundo mercado de exportación más
grande para Rusia después de la Unión Europea.)
El lado bueno de esta relación económica
ya lo hemos visto.
Rusia necesita a China como un mercado gigantesco
al que exportar sus materias primas.
Pero comerciar con China también tiene riesgos.
Hablemos por ejemplo de armamento.
Rusia es el mayor proveedor de equipos militares
de China.
En la década pasada proporcionó el 70% de
las importaciones de armas del gigante asiático.
Pekín ha comprado su armamento más avanzado,
como los aviones Sukhoi Su-35 y los sistemas
antiaéreos S-400.
Sin embargo, amigos, todo indica que en el
futuro China no necesitará importar tantas
armas rusas.
¿Por qué digo esto?
Pues por noticias como estas.
(Rusia en pie de guerra por el robo chino
de tecnología militar)
(La principal agencia rusa de diseño de submarinos
sufre un ciberataque con características
chinas)
China y Rusia han sido tradicionalmente rivales.
Y este tipo de noticias puede despertar la
desconfianza del Kremlin.
Algo que también tiene consecuencias para
la OCS.
Por un lado, Rusia se ha negado rotundamente
a que la OCS se convierta en un área de libre
comercio.
No quiere que los productos chinos inunden
el mercado ruso y arruinen a sus productores.
Por otro lado, el Kremlin ha sido el principal
impulsor de la entrada de India en la OCS.
Y mucho ojo porque esta expansión hacia el
Índico puede haber significado que esta organización
haya quedado herida de muerte.
Entre otras cosas, porque, sí, Rusia se salió
con la suya al incorporar a la India para
contrarrestar el excesivo peso de China dentro
de la organización.
Pero es que Pekín exigió también la entrada
de su firme aliado pakistaní.
Y claro, juntar a indios y pakistaníes en
la misma sala no puede salir bien.
Mirad.
(India abandona la reunión de la OCS después
de que el representante pakistaní proyecte
un “mapa ficticio” )
Recordad que la OCS toma todas sus decisiones
por unanimidad.
Así que parece que la Organización de Cooperación
de Shanghai se ha pegado un tiro en el pie.
Y luego, además, tenemos que tener en cuenta
que tanto China como Rusia tienen su propio
plan B para la región.
Pekín lleva años trabajando en la nueva
ruta de la seda, una inversión multimillonaria
en infraestructuras con las que extender la
influencia económica y comercial de China
en el mundo.
Y Moscú lidera la Unión Económica Euroasiática,
un proyecto que pretende imitar a la Comunidad
Económica Europea, el germen de la actual
Unión Europea.
Al final, la clave de todo esto es que Rusia
sigue queriendo tratar de tú a tú a China.
Y, claro, hay serias dudas de que realmente
pueda hacerlo.
Pero la cuestión, la cuestión más importante,
es que todas estas controversias nos muestran
una realidad que no siempre se tiene en cuenta:
las relaciones entre Rusia y China no son
tan buenas como aparentan ser.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Crees que la Organización de Cooperación
de Shanghai puede tener futuro?
¿Consideráis que Rusia se beneficia de su
buena relación comercial con China o corre
peligro de convertirse en un rehén más de
Pekín?
Podéis dejarnos vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios.
Si el vídeo te ha resultado interesante dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si aun no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.